I love [ __ ] losing I do laughing guy
you're part of a generation that was
protected from losing you need to break
the [ __ ] out of it you got your
perspective Thank You Brizzy how are you
guys awesome thank you so much just
Withers I saw your tweets I'm sorry I
got love for you anyway please sit let's
get into this so I asked them to flip
the format so instead of 40 minute
keynote 20 QA I've decided to go 20
minute cute keynote 40 QA the mics are
lined up in the corners there I highly
recommend you get up now and start
lining up so that you get your question
because 80% of the people didn't get
their question in Sydney so if you want
a QA that's where those are please try
not to block the people so real quick
you know I've been thinking a lot about
a couple things
and during in an interview today
something kind of populated in my mind
that really stood out that I want to
start with which is I've come to realize
that so much is working for me because
on papers so much did not work for me as
a child you know when you're born in a
different country and you move and you
immigrate there's always going to be
struggles within that and so I was born
in the Soviet Union we came to the US
when I was three and you know I lived in
a studio apartment with multiple family
members it was not glamorous I had to
learn the language and at five and four
and five years old got picked on quite a
bit for not being able to speak English
I was an all-time atrocious student
which meant my teachers and the parents
of my best friends basically [ __ ] on me
and told me I wouldn't be successful I
was not ridiculously physically gifted
for athletics so I wasn't dominating in
sports and so when I think about
what makes me happy forget about
financially successful because it to be
very frank something that I've decided
I'm gonna spend the next 80 years of my
life on is I genuinely think as a
society we have to redefine success and
dramatically start downplaying money and
start playing up happiness I am I
appreciate that and I and I really mean
it by the way uh no question to me one
of the reasons I think I'm a successful
entrepreneur is cuz I love the game not
the trophies that come from winning the
game and I think that a lot of people
are chasing money because they want to
buy [ __ ] to conceal insecurities and
unhappiness because we're so worried
about judgment from everybody else or to
prove to everybody else we're winning
and it's completely [ __ ] and we need
to completely transform it and I'm
thinking a lot about that but on that
note all that losing as a kid made me
not fear it the the enormous reason I'm
gonna rant for another 16 50 seconds and
tell you to produce an ungodly amount of
content on Facebook Twitter Linkedin
Instagram YouTube podcast I will rant
and I will push and I will prod and I'll
come up with four classic analogies and
to new ones because I love improv and
I'm gonna basically try to will down
your [ __ ] throat the thought that you
need to put out pictures video and
written word on the internet on this
device at scale because the fact that we
get to be humans during this internet
era where you get to post [ __ ] for free
and get free distribution and yes
eventually the organic reach of the
algorithm goes down and everybody
[ __ ] cries about it but let me remind
all of you it's [ __ ] free I will sit
here and pound that message down your
throat I will talk about self awareness
how you have to be good and figure out
what you're good at are you comfortable
in front of a camera no no big deal
audio clip it great you're not good at
that right I don't care how you do it I
definitely don't think you should do it
like I do it I do it my way
but if you are not producing content
around your business or whatever you're
trying to achieve by being here you are
happy in a place where you will continue
to lose leverage while the person that
does produce content for Facebook
Twitter Instagram tik-tok LinkedIn
YouTube they will continue to gain
leverage it's as simple as that
everything that has happened in society
around the human race over the last
forever years has been predicated on
communication everything that you're
talking about in your life
parenting politics business
entertainment is completely predicated
on contextual contemporary communication
and I have really nothing else to say I
can literally [ __ ] leave the stage
right now and feel good I mean that I I
couldn't be more passionate around
getting everybody to understand that
wherever we go with the QA right now
it's all gonna lead to one thing which
is do you understand yourself and what
you're trying to achieve are you in a
place where you've actually started the
process of not worrying about what your
parents or your friends or your spouse
thinks about you and once you get into
that good place you will not fear to
post content on I do not fear posting
content of me taking you know a Saturday
and garage saleing and buying something
for four dollars and selling it for
eight dollars and having enormous joy in
that even though hundreds of comments on
YouTube are well you lost money because
of fuel and time I don't give a [ __ ]
Larry I do not fear about putting out
the content that I will put over the
next month about everybody should invest
in sports cards because I think I'm
right and I don't care if you think I'm
stupid or it's a waste of time you can
only start communicating and getting
results for your business when you
believe the amount of people sitting in
this room that actually don't believe in
the [ __ ] they sell is devastating you're
selling it because you want money you
know many people right now are
Annabeth's and cryptocurrency expert and
five minutes ago they were a social
media expert and a week ago they were
[ __ ] real estate expert
you're [ __ ] chasing and I don't think
that's a good strategy
there is nothing passive about building
wealth there is no [ __ ] system
there's no [ __ ] shortcut it's a
[ __ ] marathon I [ __ ] worked every
day for 15 years before I put out a
piece of content in my life you're not
getting there quick nobody's [ __ ]
inventing uber in this [ __ ] room we
need to quantify what's happening here
and what's happening here is we are
ridiculously lucky to be living right
now because our grandparents didn't have
the ability to have the Internet in
their pocket this computer that I'm
holding in my hands is more powerful
than the computer that Ronald Reagan had
running America in the 80s that is
insanity
we have completely not contextualized
the opportunity the other thing that we
have not contextualized is time if
there's been any breakthrough in my mind
over the last half decade it's oh [ __ ]
my ability to contextualize time
slightly better than the masses is why
I'm so happy of course I can be patient
when I think 43 is young as [ __ ] now
many people are sitting here at 28
[ __ ] nervous as [ __ ] thinking they
missed their moment we need to
contextualize time when you start
thinking in long terms I mean how many
people under 40 in this room raise your
hand when you realize that you're gonna
live two more full lives full lives two
more what you've just lived up to this
moment that you're gonna do that two
more full times all of a sudden not
getting results tomorrow feels a little
bit more palpable we lack patience we
lack patience which leads to [ __ ]
behavior because you're looking for a
quick score it's the same old [ __ ]
business is no different than Fitness
business is no different than Fitness
you want to get more fit eat healthy and
workout but nobody wants to [ __ ] do
it
cuz [ __ ] chocolate and sleeping in is
fun and celery and [ __ ] treadmills
suck [ __ ] the reason so many people
don't like my content is I've got no
[ __ ] quick move for you I don't have
it I have no interest in selling you
anything or giving you some [ __ ]
trick or [ __ ] pandering and showing
you how good I have it so you want it
like me here's what I know about
entrepreneurship it's lonely as [ __ ]
this game is lonely you know what
entrepreneurship is you're on at all
times
I've got [ __ ] five offices globally
and right now there might be a leak in
the Singapore office and that's my
[ __ ] problem right it takes a lot of
work it takes a lot of work and it takes
a long long long time we are now in the
era where entrepreneurship is cool for
everybody who is 35 and older we grew up
when it wasn't cool for everybody who's
25 and younger people like me seem cool
now we were [ __ ] dorks in the 80s and
you have to understand that's fine but
what that makes me fearful of is the
following unless you love your game
somebody else who loves it more is gonna
work harder and smarter and beat you
please understand that self-awareness
and patience are their foundation of a
happy successful business and there are
words that are not being talked about at
all you know why so many people here
don't have the Instagram following they
want or aspire to it's because every
[ __ ] piece of content you put out is
selfish not selfless you care about how
many likes I'm so [ __ ] pumped that the
likes are gone in this country it's the
single best thing it really is your
pandering to short-term metrics and
putting out [ __ ] that you're not even
happy about cuz subconsciously you know
it will do better than the [ __ ] that you
actually want to talk about we are
living in really
interesting times and I come here this
evening with one specific agenda which
is unless you were 100% committed to
your audience and playing a ridiculous
long game you were going to become more
and more vulnerable every day because
people that are are gonna put out
content do you know how many [ __ ]
scam artists I [ __ ] up by giving out
all my information for free there is no
$8,000 ebook with me and that is what is
going to happen everywhere whoever
brings the most value is going to win
and unless that's your framework
you will become vulnerable and I highly
recommend you heed this call I highly
recommend it how many people here have
more than 10 employees raise your hand
really interesting subject for me I've
been spending a ton of time on
it's amazing to me for whatever reason
DNA wise how I believe that I have a
thousand employees and that means I work
for a thousand people versus they work
for me I'm watching enormous
mismanagement at people with employees
how do i Botev eight my employees to
care like me you don't you want your
employees to care like you give them
equal equity like you have you know I'm
watching all these patterns and it's
just really exciting for me to try to
get people to understand what's
happening and what the opportunity is
and that my friends is we are now
finally at maturity of the internet
people have it on their phone 24/7 we
are at scale we're in the mix now this
is real life this is secondary
you don't like it sorry but that is how
it's playing out and unless you are good
at this you become unbelievably
vulnerable so let me let me sneak in
some tactics before I go into queue a
couple things that are just important
and I know a lot of people look to me
for I never know what's next
you know inevitably somebody's gonna ask
me Gary but what's the next platform
you're always so right I don't know I
just know what's current and a lot of
times that feels like I'm predict
thing but all I'm doing is moving
quickly in the reality here's what I can
tell you is going on in Australia
specifically if you are not producing an
enormous amount of content for LinkedIn
you are missing out on Facebook 2011
regardless of your b2b or b2c whether
you sell bikinis direct-to-consumer or
you have a consulting firm if you are
not producing content right now for
LinkedIn you were missing a monster
opportunity the organic reach of just
posting on LinkedIn as if it was
Facebook 9 years ago is that a level
that I haven't seen since Facebook I
couldn't recommend it more for every
single person here regardless of your
business it has gone away from being a
recruiting tool to a Content microphone
number two influencer marketing it
continues to be one of the most
underpriced executions in the world it's
gotten mature there are absolutely
people with huge followings that are now
overpriced
but the long tail of influencer
marketing is a remarkable arbitrage and
I highly recommend you get more educated
on that environment tick tock tick tock
is fascinating to me because I keep
watching people make the same mistakes
over and over literally the same person
that [ __ ] on Instagram seven years ago
saying it was for their kids and then
tried to catch up two years ago is
[ __ ] on tick tock right now saying
it's their kids whether tick tock
becomes something as big as Instagram
and mainstream for all ages I'm not sure
but it is at such scale at this point
and enough people over the age of 20 are
going on the platform at scale that now
for this entire room if you're a 67 year
old lawyer I want to know what the [ __ ]
your tick-tock strategy is and so for me
everyone's always looking for it's
amazing they want the answer and then
when you give it to them they want to
push against it it's right in your face
I highly recommend you start auditing
and spend five to ten hours on tick-tock
consume you'll see plenty of dumb [ __ ]
plenty of lipping and dancing and music
but be thoughtful sir
your hashtags and see what's in there
this takes work I spend all my hours
listening it seems like I'm always
talking it's because I spend every
second you don't see me listening i
watch those three observations are tried
and true I will as you know how many
people here to consume my content thank
you I will like you've seen me do replay
this exact video in nine years basically
with a headline of Brizzy I [ __ ] told
you why didn't you do it this is what's
going to happen so please heed those
three opportunities and get educated if
you look why the [ __ ] are you here like
if you're here for some reason which is
I assume you want something good to
happen after you [ __ ] allocated this
day for me if you've allocated this time
which I'm so humbled by to listen to
this information I'm desperate to figure
out how to get you to do something with
the information to to be in a place
where you want more for yourself
whatever that may be happiness dollars I
I don't get the judge you do you please
do the ten hours of work that I just
asked you to do to actually read and
watch on those three executions and do
something my friends you can't read
about push-ups you have to do them you
can't read or listen to what I'm saying
you have to do it and that's what got me
over the last three years into this part
of it I couldn't understand five or six
years ago when I was handing you the
keys why you weren't dropping driving
that car and what I ended up realizing
was it was all up here
there's a stunning amount of fear in
this room about putting out content how
you look what you're gonna say what are
the comments gonna say just a crippling
amount of inaction
because of the fear of people's opinions
that you don't even know and even worse
opinions of the people you love the most
and so for me that has become an
incredibly important place for me to
focus on so for me I just have no
interest in being half pregnant I have
no interest in being stuck in the middle
there's only two things for me the macro
which is why are you living your life
based on other people's opinions and
then the micro what are the tactics the
individual executions that actually get
you to what you want the biggest thing
that I would love for this room to start
doing is to start really thinking about
the notion of being great at producing
written words audio and video per the
ten platforms so that it's contextual to
the platform I just pushed a lot of you
to do LinkedIn looking at this room
eleven of you will do it of those eleven
if you're listening right now remember
this when somebody's on LinkedIn and
going through the content they're in a
business mindset when they're on
Instagram they're on an entertainment
mindset so the way you convey your
message is extremely important the
adjectives you use the analogies you use
the examples you use it has to base on
the psychology every one of us is in a
different place when we're on different
platforms you have to pander you have to
be contextual to that so whatever you
have to say about what you're doing make
sure you're being empathetic and
strategic to how they're thinking when
they see it that is why I do well on
each platform I strategize around the
content in reverse engineering the
psychology in the same way that I'm
trying to do that as I'm on this stage
right now what for an audience that has
so much content that they've consumed
for me can I say right now it's why I
took 40 minutes and switched it because
you can hear this [ __ ] every [ __ ] day
because I'm consistent as [ __ ] but what
I get to do right now is use the QA to
be contextual as [ __ ] thank you busy
[Applause]
I'm ready for questions what's up bro is
it on yet Sauron what you seen hey doing
Gary on brick Campbell co-founder of
klaxon our digital growth agency I had
the opportunity on Tuesday to fly down
and hang out with Grant Cardone for a
couple of hours and got to interview him
and I asked him this particular question
and believe it or not probably for the
first time he actually stopped him
paused and actually had to think of an
answer and I wanted to ask you the same
question
so imagine Mark Zuckerberg slides into
your DMS he says hey Gary what's up
you're like [ __ ] hustling he's like
of course you are I want to ask you one
thing and he says Gary I want you to
take over Facebook tomorrow good and you
can post one post that every single user
on Facebook will see for the entire day
what would that post be how can I help
you and why because I want to help I
didn't have to [ __ ] think
[Applause]
I don't have to [ __ ] think fellas
when your framework is selfless the
answer is easy when your framework is
selfish it's hard what up hi Gary
I'm Michelle hi Michelle I'm from selfie
frames Australia it's nice to meet you
you too I started the business as a
little side hustle basically to pay
debts and tax bills okay and I stumbled
across you and you gave me a kick in the
ass to realize that it can be something
bigger than just paying off [ __ ] great
time so I've just got this hole of move
from just shitty life paying off bills
to holy [ __ ] this could be a big thing I
like that with regard to your post on
social media hey you're saying don't be
selfish about it
yes I'm selling frames that are
customized for parties and stuff okay
how am I supposed to make that unselfish
like how am I supposed to help people
like you help people everyday with the
[ __ ] that you do yes I'm selling frames
and parties weren't easy what what's
amazing is think about the answer I just
gave you could just post hey I make
frames for parties but if you have any
questions about parties in general and
now you may not have the answers but you
just have to start with what else can I
hint give you within the framework of my
ecosystem the reason I built the biggest
wine show on the internet in the
mid-2000s was I wasn't trying to sell
wine I was trying to educate people
about wine and if I happen to sell wine
I was thrilled
there's nothing by the way back to the
last thing there's nothing wrong with
being selfish I'm selfish I want to buy
the New York Jets the value though is
the punchline when you slow it down and
you play over 50 years when you give
more than you take you end up with a
fuckload and so what you can do is buy
it you can start by asking a question
you can literally go back to your seat
right now take the
camera on whatever you're posting on and
say hey I've been telling you about the
frames right yeah what do you guys want
for me what else can I be doing for you
what questions do you have for me and
then read those questions and that will
give you the insight to how you bring
value I didn't know that I needed to
talk about parent and kid dynamics I
just read all the DMS from the parents
and the kids and that led me to having
an understanding that there was
something there to talk about
okay got it thank you so much Gary ash
Cohen how do you disagree with the
status quo by raising your audience's
heart math without seeming like no at
all a heckler or a troll by ending up
being right correct thank you for
everything you might and that's the
punch line right to that answer like so
many of the things I say at first are
pushed against which I respect when
you're innovating me and and pushing
against the status quo people are gonna
disagree with you that's the nature of
it I don't think that I deserve to be
right I just know that if I am right
over time it builds reputation I get
away with a lot more today than I did 15
years ago because of being historically
correct
hey did I go okay my name is Ethan I'm
19 I'm a union at the moment and I've
been following for years now I love all
the stuff you're doing with your cloud
and dirty empathy wine vaynermedia all
the stuff I love hey like
diversification really with the
portfolio my question really was at this
point I know I'm young and patience is
key I've got a lot of what different
avenues I like that appeal to different
morals and he said I value okay
how you give that 100% to everything or
cuz like I feel like I'm giving 20% to
five different things to add up to I
probably you know listen there's a lot
of ways to do this right so the way I
stay focused is by not being focused
that's my DNA I need a lot of stimuli
and my big game is
if I'm throwing 30 balls in the air if
eight fall eh I don't care about your
collective judgment that I had eight
things fail and I still have twenty two
balls in the air that's what works for
me I have tons of people I surround
myself who are only good at having one
ball and they crushed that ball like
crazy and that's amazing to what I would
say for you is you can you can play both
you can try to go five times twenty
percent see what that does you may learn
during that time that you actually love
number four and you decide to give that
eighty percent and the others five yeah
okay what I'm just thinking at that
point 100 I always got the fear of like
if I got a hundred percent I'm gonna
[ __ ] up and then I've to the question
you know where you're where it's an
issue yeah you're thinking yeah I ever
think bro
everybody over thinks everybody's so
[ __ ] insecure about losing that they
think which makes them never do which
keeps them away from losing reverse it
and don't give a [ __ ] about what people
think about your loss and [ __ ] gets real
fun I love [ __ ] losing I do laughing
guy you're part of a generation that was
protected from losing you need to break
the [ __ ] out of it okay thank you Gary
got it Garvey bro yo my name is Alex
thank you cuz my opinion you're the
[ __ ] man at the end my question
to you is as someone who's Slavik myself
I come from a real old-school log
parents right in my gut I know I'm
getting everything but how do I showcase
that'll keep their fear out of my mind
when all they want is the traditional
get married get a house get kids whereas
in my mind I just I just want to figure
it out and I've happily just quit my
10th job I'm gonna keep going off her
till I figure it out
but man you know what Slovak parents are
like man how do you how do you balance
both but go off through it all at the
same time by recognizing how sweet it is
when you succeed on your own terms
how proud they'll be about you
too many too many kids struggle with
conflict with parents in the short-term
without realizing that parents always
fall into line after you're successful
and by also having the humility that if
you're wrong to admit that you're wrong
20 years from now and adjust you know
what I mean
listen everybody at some level whether
they have good parents or bad parents
want to make their parents proud it's a
[ __ ] inherent thing of coming out of
somebody's body right it's it is when I
say don't listen to anybody and go quiet
I mean everybody especially parents
spouses siblings especially but here's
the key when you just said Gary Vee I
think you're the [ __ ] minute
where people get caught is they get too
high on compliments and too low on
insults nothing makes me happier than
when I read my comments where one post
is Gary Vee you're just hot air [ __ ] you
right and the next ones like Gary you're
[ __ ] Jesus you walk on water and I
look at those two and I'm like this is
why I'm gonna win I can't hear either of
them where so many of you are [ __ ] up
is you hear the cheering but you're
crippled by the booing you're addicted
to the cheering but you don't want to
hear the booing I respect both equally
which means I can't hear either either
you're gonna be right or they're gonna
be right I feel the way you deliberate
your sentence that you're gonna be right
I think you need to limit how much you
listen to them
I appreciate you God I'll see you soon
see you soon yeah yeah yeah you lost
your voice no this is your actual
[ __ ] voice it is a cry all right
it is my voice oh it's [ __ ] weird we
tracked it to you I'm Marco from the
sunny Coast in Queensland I've been
calling you for that - this is not your
[ __ ] voice bro all right all right
sorry I recognize gay
work with the old people I do that's a
full-time job that's the bad way I work
with 100 year old 100 zones 100 year
olds and I find that very and rewarding
I great and a lot of people hate to talk
about death yes look they're [ __ ]
stitch scared talking outdance so I want
to start up I don't want to start
talking about death and having young
people coming to my field so I get more
young people I love that it's my field
so what's that noise give me talk a lot
that's the advice yep talk you said you
wanted to talk about it my advice is to
talk about it you know this is what I
set my opening chant with right which is
that you've been consuming my content I
don't think there's any confusion that I
think you should be making content the
question is why haven't you I have yes
more MORE do you have a podcast tell the
truth cuz I [ __ ] check and blow I did
I you don't have a podcast next day I
got Twitter
no no Twitter's not a [ __ ] podcast
bro the [ __ ] are you talking about
right thank you you need a podcast I
think I've made myself perfectly clear
you post five times a day on LinkedIn no
no I'm gonna [ __ ] check so don't
[ __ ] will blow you up on your how
many times do you tweet a day it was
cute
brother the answer is content okay your
one video away from striking a chord and
having 20 million Australians know what
you think about death give yourself that
chance we need to stop playing in our
own heads and we start need to start
playing in real life make content I got
that you got it thanks dad you got a
brother
Gary bro
dad Dylan Dylan I'll keep a longer story
of short respect everyone else's time
been through the ringer nearly lost my
marriage did lose a business went back
to working for someone got the craps
with that and I have built here a
business since then because of I found a
certain well he probably found me a guy
on Facebook
okay tell it to swear and you know a lot
of patience for people so one I just
wanted to take this opportunity to thank
you and I didn't want to have the regret
the death that I didn't do that in
person thank you you've got no idea
might you completely change my whole
entire [ __ ] life thank you so much
crazy thank you the question though I
have unfortunately cuz I went through
that not so great period a hunter a
young family that's yeah and I think
that period of time is actually damaged
a little bit of the psychology of my
eldest son okay and he he doesn't he
doesn't cope well at all with anything
change is one of the biggest things he
struggles with yeah we say we're gonna
do something and we change it midway
through it just reals on it understood
have you got any more before you go any
further please don't just jump into the
thought that that period is what created
that it's super important that you don't
over judge yourself it may have but with
all due respect it may have not yeah
that just might be a DNA trait from your
great uncle Gilbert you know what I was
a little bit locked up myself as well
even even better so before you start
this process of beating you the [ __ ] up
one of the biggest things that I'm
trying to figure out and I'm super early
which is why I'm not talking about it
but before we worry about the judgment
from the outside
most people are crippled by the
judgement of themselves through
themselves without realizing somebody
else put that judgment in them so before
we even allow the framework that your
actions did that I'd like to take a step
back because the second you can take a
little that pressure off it changes the
way
that you could maybe deal with it yeah
you know also how old is he 12
I mean it's early and all you have to do
is love and listen you can't impose what
you want him to be you need to watch
carefully
and react to what he actually is if he
doesn't like change he may not be an
entrepreneur and guess what that's
amazing I have no interest in my
children being entrepreneurs I've
interest in them loving what they do the
way I love what I do and whether that
makes four dollars a year or not that's
it and by the way I'm not gonna give
them any of my money either so if they
make four dollars a year they're gonna
[ __ ] live on four dollars a year and
guess what there's a lot of [ __ ] in
this room making 40,000 a year that are
way happier than the millionaires in
this [ __ ] hall thank you Gary I love
you back - hey what's going on Gary life
is good bro great shirt thanks man I
made it myself
nice hey yo so I went three businesses
at the current stage wants a nightclub
ones also touring company nightclubs
doing a gold year last three years we
gold
line up absolutely at the door smash
packed but the touring is really good -
a tiger a few months ago sold out it was
good I started a site on us a couple
years ago when I first met you Gary and
I asked you you actually used that piece
of content on your Instagram and other
social medias I know if I rang a bell to
you then but I basically asked you I
said are my nightclubs called shades my
toric company's called shades
everybody's telling me don't call your
printing company shades you said [ __ ]
them I did that it's now called shades
custom printing and things are going
good man I went from a little pop-up
store inside like a little marketplace
sort of thing so now having a permanent
store
all through businesses man so I have a
four point five million dollars an
estate investor thank you and also can I
take a selfie say every time a garnish
aids custom printing office I've got a
photo of you with me there just to say
thank you come up Libya
coming up let me let me tell you what I
remember about that question and this
back to trying to make this valuable for
everybody always pay attention to who's
giving you the advice what I remembered
about your question I remember it was
the people that were telling you to
knock college shades haven't built a
business there's too many people here
taking advice from people that have
never done it themselves I always like
to take advice from an executor over an
educator
[Applause]
you could save it
yo hey Gary how are you how are you
Henry yeah I'm good thanks great um so
you know I'm one of those truckers that
say like I want to make a business and
all that stuff and I've been doing a
little soul-searching and like you know
how every business you want to help
you've way I I do find like a lot of
fulfillment when I like you know help
people and like go out and do stuff for
people but at the same time I'm kind of
like purflex right now because I'd much
rather spend like an afternoon playing
basketball then going to volunteer
somewhere so that's why I'm just
wondering am I like a hypocrite right
now or yeah I'm like [ __ ] basketball
so so then in terms of like passion then
like you should start a basketball
business being serious okay what why do
you want to have a business well as mean
stained basically you could work
somewhere as a means to an end
yeah you know that that's the thing that
I'm trying to really have conversations
around this new notion that everybody
needs to have a business is laughable
nine out of ten you know small
businesses fail nine out of ten people
never even try to do a small business
it's hard it's a talent everybody thinks
like now because of the way the internet
works and entrepreneurship is cool that
like I'm gonna have a business that's
like everybody's saying I'm gonna play
professional basketball that's nice but
you know my intuition is you don't have
to have a business right but also in
terms of like if you say your passion is
helping people but you'd much rather do
something else can help people 24/7
every day yeah right it's it's likely
that playing basketball helps you help
people yeah true yeah yeah all right
good all right thanks a lot
[Applause]
hey Gary what's up bro I'm from Brisbane
and dude I just wanna say thank you for
just being such an inspiration to my
generation and generation come it's
thank you [ __ ] awesome thank you my
biggest question right now is the fact
that I completely agree with you like
what you're saying 100% do content and
being for a long time
that's the 20 80 8020 rule you do the
basic you clouds and as you talk about
biggest question is that not necessary
why don't we don't why don't we do it
because there's a massive knowing doing
it but especially as we get more
information it's more about how do we
get [ __ ] done how can we make the rubber
hit the road and also stick to it by
liking it like if you think it's a chore
you're [ __ ] see like that one it's
true though like like if you're doing
content hardcore cuz I told you so but
you hate it you're finished which is why
I keep talking about self-awareness this
is why I'm so scared that I'm the Pied
Piper for making content cuz I have a
unique personality I want to remind
people that there are plenty people
bigger than me more successful than me
that are very introverted and just write
incredibly well and don't make a single
charismatic video in their lives you
have to you have to make content that
works for you does that make sense
that's why when I created in that
interview with that kid the document
don't create it unlocked for so many
people because they were crippled by
being creative because they're not
creative but documenting was easy it's
why I like podcasts cuz you can have a
guest on and you just have to ask
questions and their content is being
made so ultimately you just need to
choose the [ __ ] sandwich you want to eat
consistently no you have to find a
sandwich that doesn't taste like [ __ ]
bad points at that point
thanks Gary
Oh Gary hey Hogan and my name is Birkin
first thing I [ __ ] love you know a
legend and secondly my my question
relates to tick-tock you kind of spoke
about it a little bit towards the end
there but I was already in the line and
it was too late to change my mind and
not ask the question so here we got em
strategies in terms of tick-tock I am a
sales college currently and I want to
start posting more on tick-tock I do
Instagram and Facebook already would you
recommend it I would do I would do 10
things the way you exactly do them
elsewhere and watch them not work I
would consume a shitload of content on
tick-tock and see trends and then I
would mimic those trends in your
interpretation for example one of the
trends on tick-tock is to actually film
another phone of your content on a
different platform and talk over it so
you could literally take one phone play
your sales video on on Facebook and then
record with another phone and talk over
and say hey kids because you know it's
younger this is what I'm saying on
Facebook the version for you to practice
now is this see where I'm going yeah you
have to come up you have to consume the
reason I always do well is I listen for
hundreds of hours before I talk it's not
obvious to you because you're only
seeing the talking part you don't see
the 14 hours that I put in in listening
to tick-tock content on the flight here
right it's the same reason I'm gonna
crush sports cards this flight here
wasn't tick-tock it was forts cards you
know eventually under who's gonna be
like how are you write about soccer and
wrestling and basketball cards it's
because I read for 14 hours the sale
prices on auctions on those categories
and then read articles and then went on
Twitter and searched for a few people
talking about I put in the [ __ ] work
you don't need me to give you the
strategy for tick-tock go live in
tick-tock for a hundred hours and you'll
figure it out thank you you got it
[Applause]
Gary yes it's good
my name is honey honey yes sir I've just
saw my first client doing social media
marketing and weeks ago and the first
thing I did was buy ticket to come see
you okay thank you I realized actually
minutes before I got here but I'm a very
little fish I don't know [ __ ] that's
actually really exciting because I
actually gave my number to someone who
has a global auditioning and marketing
agency just an hour ago
good for you um my question will I just
want advice okay I just recently became
a single mum okay and my son is 3
because well on this journey I guess I'm
[ __ ] terrified but I'm also very
excited that's good just any piece of
advice one first of all everything I
hear it feels really good to me you know
I think it's natural if you're a single
mom with three year old who's starting a
business to both be excited and to be
fearful but let me promise you this
showing your child how to live versus
telling them how to live always works
out in the end so any moment that you
feel you know selfish or guilty that
you're putting into the business and not
the three-year-old pays out more
dividends than a lot of parents feel at
the time so I would just tell you to not
over judge yourself during this process
[Applause]
Gary my man my name's Sanjay you done
really well man mate I work 70 to 80
hour weeks like a lot of people yeah but
at the end of every day I'm absolutely
exhausted no energy left but I notice
there's some entrepreneurs like yourself
you guys seem to generate more energy
the more you work at the motor you get
how you do it
how do you get that in it I [ __ ]
collapse when I walk in like when I walk
in at 11 or 12 p.m. I'm asleep within
eight seconds how are you bringing all
that energy all day where's it I really
like what I'm doing you know how much
energy I didn't school dick
I think the more you like it and listen
there's also like you know that's like
me asking you how you have a great head
of hair like at some level some people
just have been DNA like I've always had
a fuckload of energy that's just what I
was given right so I also think for me
specifically the combination of natural
energy that was handed to me with
whatever chemical infrastructure I have
plus genuinely liking what I do
that's how so you say the passion and
the love is where you get the energy
from bro every single person that chases
cash over loving the process ends up far
less happy than people think all of them
that's my answer I'm on it man thank you
you got it hi Gary
how are you I'm good how are you super
duper
thank you my name is Marissa hi Marissa
I'm in the IT industry okay so my whole
family and friends come to me for IT
advice right and I've I'm a software
test a full time ok and I have my
part-time web design business guys
because my family wanted me to make them
websites understood and I also have a
ton of ideas good I don't know if I
should do all of them at once or should
I just focus on one idea what sounds
more fun all of them do that okay thank
you you're welcome I really think that a
lot of people are like me and want to do
all of them and people that tell you to
focus on one are people that are
successful at focusing at one you know
and I'm successful at focusing at a lot
I just think you should see your
intuition through and if you learned
that you I'm good at it
a lot of people suck at it the best way
to know what to do is to pick one do it
obviously if you pick focusing on one
you'll never know if you're good at
focusing on five if you pick focusing on
five and you [ __ ] up you know to go
focus at one
it's how I think about employees hiring
is guessing
firing is knowing so i spent very little
time hiring the answer is pretty much
yes and that's where i think i flip a
lot of things in the way that people do
things that's worked for me and i see it
working for others hey how are you real
good bro
my name's lamb it's funny you mentioned
education before cuz my initiative
supports young teachers okay hopefully
making them not like the teachers that
you might admire we're getting to a
stage now where we're dealing with
bigger more established organizations
okay some are linked to the government
make sense
when i've been dealing with them the
opinion has been very anti technology
very anti social media of course when i
talked to them they were you know static
web pages with no interactivity no
instagram no facebook but we have to
work with them to get bigger okay and
they're almost seeing my opinions is
like a threats or something along those
lines that's exactly what they think how
would you what would be your advice to
help deal with an industry that's
inherently negative about social media
promotion not be at the mercy of it like
you are now you've built a model that
relies on them right yeah i recommend
not to otherwise you have to play by
their rules which means you will get
frustrated and quit eventually anyway
so i would reframe the model to have
leverage outside of them not play within
them now that's a [ __ ] brain twist
for you because you're like [ __ ] that
means i have to start all over that's
what i'm actually telling you to do if
you're frustrated by it or eat the [ __ ]
sandwich for the rest of your life
because you chose to play within their
[ __ ] old school [ __ ] framework
well conversations are kind of just
beginning so i'll guys tell them that i
mean you know where those conversations
are gonna you are what innovation is
inherently against education it
education is built on the foundation of
memorizing information in a world where
information is at your fingertips that's
a problem we don't give a [ __ ] when it
[ __ ] up retailers and we have new
internet retailers but we're awfully
romantic about education education
framework is broke the internet [ __ ]
it that's not something I or you have
anything to do with but if you choose to
play within it you choose to play within
it it's like kids that always hit me
after I Gary my parents are forcing me
to go to [ __ ] school like I don't
[ __ ] want to do this I want to start
a business I'm like leave all these kids
talking [ __ ] but they want mommy's money
don't take mommy's money and [ __ ]
start a business
eat [ __ ] for a decade and do your thing
but no everybody wants both you're not
gonna be able to have both bro they're
not gonna move they'll appease you and
run you around until you quit so what
don't fight them you can't fight them
they have all the [ __ ] leverage what
you gonna fight them with that awesome
coat you're wearing
you can't fight something that has all
the leverage you're asking got it yeah
whoever asks loses jeez Cheers
[Applause]
hey Gary what's up hey my name is Taryn
have been following you pretty much
since day one
thank you a few weeks ago I had a dream
about you don't worry it was PG and I
was actually hoping it was X that can be
arranged and basically I bumped into you
after a talk and I gave you this really
smart marketing idea it's similar to the
60-second Club okay and then you were
like wow that's genius holy crap
and then you offered me a job and I was
like oh holy crap is crazy and then to
be hug took a photo yeah yeah yeah good
and then and then I woke up and I saw an
advertisement for this ribbon I'm like I
the Instagram has access to my thoughts
God is telling me something God's also
telling you so sorry I had to come here
and I was wondering if I could take a
photo with you you can okay awesome and
my question is and I think it's true for
some of the people in this room is if
you have no idea what business to start
like a lot of the resources online yep
about scaling yes but like I've done
volunteer work for the past two years
psychology business background okay I
don't know what business to start at
this point in my life so how do we go
about finding out what we want to do you
know my big thing is that this young of
an age I think people should taste [ __ ]
I think of starting a business the way I
think about finding out what your
favorite food is I think you should just
go do things that intuitively feel
potentially right you know the you don't
know exactly but you know there's things
you're interested in and I would lean
into those interests okay you know
whether that's skateboarding or cooking
or on you know like education online or
sneaker flip like you have interests and
leaning into those I think work right so
my interests are basically just I like
creative things and helping people good
this is very broad you're gonna have to
go down you're gonna have to go more
narrow like you know those are feelings
you have but you have interest
underneath that you you know painting is
creative being an entrepreneur and
coming up with business ideas is
creative like there's a lot of different
versions you're gonna have to go to your
point lower
yeah you know like I also like helping
people and being creative but I
manifested that into a wine business
into a client service business into you
know into content you're gonna have to
go lower
mm-hmm cool
hey yo Marco Laura how are you is that
wrong corn how are you my wrong called
people anyways um there's money here
that was devastating all right love you
go question what are your foot I'm gonna
survive tips for students fresh after
graduating high school top five advice
for what brother for graduating high
school top five tips for graduating high
school no sorry fresh after going on
school got it
well I mean I think number one two
through five has to be self-awareness so
instead of giving you something generic
which is what the mercy is for me when
I'm putting out content
let's go different what are you actually
asking me well on script but um you [ __ ]
your script like yeah there we go what
what are you what are you trying to
write is uh what self-drive should I
have when I'm very high school or where
should i do what should I go but I've no
plans for afterwards what do you want
something on the box like play with me
here like those are that you're
regurgitating thesis like play with me
here a little bit like what do you like
the bloke from the start
um buying is selling on Amazon I
wouldn't mind getting into that that's
good do that alright sweet you know what
I mean though bro like what I'm what I'm
outrageously passionate about is you're
part of a generation like yesterday some
kid in Sydney's like bro how do I get
out of the rat race he's 16
I'm like bro you're not in the rat race
you know like something outside of the
box that's theory right that's like
jargon like to me it's like go basic
like if you enjoy look you're talking to
somebody this last week I was in Chicago
with my son and my best friend and some
of the guys on my team and we were at
this baseball card convention it was the
first time I did being a baseball card
dealer in 25 years I went to another
dealer and bought a Wayne Gretzky rookie
card for 200 bucks I brought it to my
table and priced it at 260 and it's sold
the high that I got on that $60 flip is
five million times much bigger of a high
than the six figures I'll make to give
this speech over to this last hour
they're not even in the same [ __ ]
universe I love that right that's what
you need to figure out like if you're
lucky enough to actually like buying
stuff and flipping it on Amazon that is
a business that can get you to millions
of dollars because it's so real go into
that instead of posturing with something
outside the box go in the [ __ ] box
and execute it a photo it all go it sure
[Applause]
hey Gary fish here fish a big fan thank
you
now this is a silly question I'm I'm new
to this and okay my head around things a
problem you know apologize for the fear
don't worry but so I've just started
getting into content because of you it's
been the last couple of months and I'm
in the real estate and mortgage broking
industry okay
so we've opened our own company IRA said
and the real estate industry and
mortgage broking interest rates and
stuff is not really that sexy no right
so we've tried to make it sexy by
combining it with my other passion which
is drinking fine realms I'm very excited
about what you're saying
I'm beat I'm being dead serious people
buy homes or give business to people
they associate with I think a lot of you
should be talking more about what your
favorite footy team is what what kind of
beverages you like what kind of shows
you watch on Stan and Netflix people
stay so narrow and professional when all
the opportunity is going broader of your
actual true self if you're actually
deeply passionate on single-barrel and
esoteric rums that is a gateway drug for
you to do mortgage and real estate
business I think it's a great idea okay
cool so that answer my cuz so we've
called her channel Roman real estate I
[ __ ] love it bro you know you know
what's so amazing about this interaction
you're new but your intuition is so on
that's from you I know it's not for me
it's from you yeah so no because I was
wondering because we just don't have
enough data to measure whether we're
heading in the right direction you
started exactly so [ __ ] data why don't
you make [ __ ] two years worth of
content and then think about it first
here's the good news if it's wrong
at least you drank a fuckload of good
rum and and Gary it'll be super I don't
I don't know push my luck here but if I
can take a picture that me amazing I'm
thrilled to do it I think I carry hey my
name is Raj I own a recruitment agency
in Thailand okay we've been going for
three years okay I employ ten people
awesome it's [ __ ] hard work yes I've
heard it's my question is simple you
talk a lot about loving the process yes
how do I stay in love with the process
either you are just what you do
day-to-day or you sell the company
that's the end goal to sell it that's
already the problem why because that's
why people don't like their businesses
they build them to flip okay I have no
interest in ever selling any of my
businesses now it doesn't mean I'm right
or wrong it's why you're struggling mmm
you don't love it you want the money
exactly bad yeah
I've honest about it it's true I know
you could have lied and I still would
have known you were lying yeah because
of the way you asked the question yeah I
would argue that you're playing a game
of holding your breath
so do what everybody does when they do a
business they don't love hold your
breath as long as you can and then
[ __ ] sell it or bring in a minority
partner who [ __ ] loves it and let
them operate and let them earn from 10%
to 50% over three years and then have an
infrastructure where you're aligned but
then always be prepared for her or him
to say [ __ ] you after six years cuz now
they're the only ones doing it and they
don't want to give you 50 cents of the
dollar anymore but for you at least you
extracted value over those six years and
you're happy to sell it back to her or
him at the end of that six years both of
those are options you get the pick okay
thanks but this is why and that's great
but this is why I want to talk about
this for a second this is why I'm so
passionate about people building a
business around what they love because
then you can play forever it may be a
little slow when your business is around
footy or the Smurfs or root beer because
it takes time but over time you could go
like this versus like this and you're
dealing with this and that's okay but
you have to sell you have to give up
leverage now you got it I got it are you
gonna burn out yeah you got it mmm
thanks Gary you got to be
hey guy pleasure to meet you nice to
meet you
my question you talked a lot about just
being yourself yes I'm a fan sent aware
of you know what you are capable of and
what you're not capable of but what is
like the objective bad qualities I guess
what things should you seek to improve
like for example I'm naturally an
introvert that's great very good at
selling Barbies so don't sell well then
that's fine you just need to hire
somebody who can sell fair enough
I think else whatever you're inherently
bad at hire fair enough
when you were starting Wine Library yes
you were kind of paving her way
obviously for a while before you knew it
even be successful well I was at a
unique situation cuz my dad had a liquor
store and the reason I always tell kids
to be patient was I spent 22 to 34
working six days a week Monday through
Saturday 12 hours a day built a business
from 3 to 60 million and then left
owning none of it and started my own
life at 34 so you can imagine when a 26
year old is worried about [ __ ] that I
struggle with being overly empathetic
so with Wine Library my mission was to
actually give back to my parents for
what they did for me by having me in the
first place and then raising me did you
know that what you were doing was gonna
work out yes because I'd already been
good at baseball cards and lemonade and
I knew I was good at selling right yep
okay thank you here's an important part
of the way you're asking the question I
thought there is no you know I thought
where I'm very fascinated how old are
you 19 this is my big fascination I wish
you knew that you could do nothing right
literally make every wrong decision for
the next 19 years of your life live a
tire another life and still be young as
[ __ ] to go and win like debating with
your own [ __ ] head about what's right
is actually doing [ __ ] is the biggest
reason that people fail there's a 80
year olds that are sitting here that are
still debating it's one big game of
insecurities bro when am I wrong when
you're dead like that's the beauty of
the game you don't get to be wrong until
the end you could spend the next 40
years of your life being super wrong and
then at 59 [ __ ] figure it out and have
a 10-year run that made you right life
is Forte's just cuz you're losing at
half time doesn't mean it's over like
I'm just so confused you know any 50 60
year olds are here thinking they're
wrapping it up when they're gonna live
another 40 [ __ ] years the [ __ ] are
you wrapping up I don't even get started
how many people under 30 [ __ ] you you
haven't even [ __ ] gotten to the game
yet you understand yeah the [ __ ] are you
thinking about at 19 don't do [ __ ]
worrying about if you're wrong for who
what are you [ __ ] worried about if
you're wrong
your dad's [ __ ] awesome he's recorded
the whole [ __ ] thing it's know my dad
whatever some we look how awesome life
is some weird ball dude is [ __ ]
recording the whole thing
[Applause]
you understand yeah I want to know why
the [ __ ] you're worried about being
wrong for who I think I look around and
I guess it that's already the start of a
bad sentence yeah no really don't sound
but I wonder though like what am I doing
wrong if so many people my age they're
for [ __ ] bro they're better at acting
than you are but if they're actually
making money how are they faking it
[ __ ] money bro you think your buddy that
you went to high school with that's
flashing diamonds on instagrams so
[ __ ] lucky get FOMO out of your
system their life has nothing to do with
you
[ __ ] does your buddies life have to do
with you
nothing nothing you understand yeah do
you know that if when I was 26 years old
I was ringing up my friends bottles of
champagne at the liquor store then
putting it into a box and carrying it to
their car and putting into their car for
the party they were going in at night in
that scene all of you would have thought
one person was winning and one person
was losing you would have been [ __ ]
wrong I was 26 you're 19 stop worrying
about your buddies
stop [ __ ] scrolling through a feed
and wishing you were something you're
not start focusing on what you actually
are cool cool thank you
[Applause]
I go how are you pretty good how are you
uncomfortably good my name's Peter I'm
14 years old
good and I just want to say you're a
[ __ ] legend I love you thanks Peter
um so my question is I run a small
Shopify drop shipping store I like it
and I just want to know because I don't
have much time I've school on my hands
course my mom makes me do
extracurricular activity and I just want
to know how to get the most out of the
time that I have you know I'm the only
thing you can do in that framework is
audit the free time you actually have
right and more importantly well how many
hours are you putting into it on a
normal day or weekend I try to do like
two hours per weekday dude that's a lot
like honestly I wouldn't over [ __ ]
yourself you're learning a ton it's
great it's you know you must be laughing
when I'm telling thirty eight year-olds
they're young you're [ __ ] a fetus you
know like so I think that I think that
you're in a great spot let me give you a
really good piece of advice I genuinely
think the number one thing I would tell
you is to enjoy the extracurricular
activities and the vacation that you
have in front of you over the next eight
years because when [ __ ] gets real it
gets real and there's no going back to
dumb down down time like I would weirdly
enjoy this you know what I mean
don't stress that you need to build a
million-dollar drop shipping Shopify
business learn your craft get good but
also enjoy this part of it as well
because 99.9% of this room would go back
to 1400 so I cannot take a photo with
you
you can't
[Applause]
haha how are you dude Gary how you doing
that good your sons awesome yeah yeah
Peter thanks here Garret my name is
Julian Lafitte
I have had an incredible journey I made
a lot of money very early able to build
great things work with amazing people
and I knew nothing about you nothing
until two months ago okay I have quite a
few people here that are my friends and
they said Jules you've got to come and
meet Gary okay
so I did thank you man your philosophy
is unreal
thank you Joe the philosophy that you'll
bring like this is that I can see the
consistency you started a thing saying I
am consistent as far I am I love it no
so I'm in my early 50s okay cool I made
a lot of money in the old world okay I
have no idea of the new world the good
news is it Maps very similarly all you
have to do is get educated on commodity
information the skill sets are the same
you just have to understand the new
framework and that information is free
and it's a commodity how do i is there a
place I can go to really fast track them
yes first of all [ __ ] fast track okay
[ __ ] that but there's definitely a place
you can write it down you ready yep I'll
spell it
Gogi oh oh gee al I love you it's [ __ ]
free literally no matter what you're
right you've been listening you're like
how literally go home how do I produce
content for LinkedIn enter free how do i
do influencer marketing for my caviar
business enter free how do I do a
podcast how do I make a podcast how do I
upload my podcast to iTunes enter free
yeah that's it man man I want to photo
as well and I want to acknowledge my
friends they all sitting on the back the
old 30 year olds or so 25 to 20 to 30
and they are teaching me so much nice
just the philosophy you are putting
inside of these kids
Edd's keep it up bro thank you brother
thank you so much yo what up hi what's
up Gary my name is Elise Grace hey Lisa
thanks so much for coming out to
Australia thank you I'm sure a lot of
people here are so so grateful that
you've come out thank you
I've been watching you since 2016 I I
started a media company shelved it
because I wasn't loving it like you said
you got to love it yeah I wanted to can
it before I grew into a beast that I
hated and more recently I've had a
thinking I love people I love talking to
people I love learning from especially
multi millionaires and billionaires
because they're on another another level
so I I started a podcast I am
interviewed one local entrepreneur
Phillip DiBella he's amazing and I would
like to ask you if you'd be a guest on
my podcast before before you shoot me
down because I've only had one interview
I want to say that I like the probably
right awesome thank you you're welcome
just email me so just I just finished by
saying I wanted I wanted to ask you as a
little fish to show people that you just
have to ask sometimes and we're doing it
so that's that's awesome thank you and
welcome
can I come grab a snap with you before I
take a listen now you're [ __ ] pusher
okay okay I'll leave it to good cast
they were getting scary you're welcome I
go make Joel here come after me I don't
know how are you good mate really well
thanks things coming out a quick
question about VR future of ER yes for
businesses yes between ease and content
creation yes ever Tizen within VR world
have been built I think it's a million
years away okay
there's not a single [ __ ] person here
that goes on VR for an hour a day it's
great in theory it's not even close
who here goes home and spends an hour in
a VR headset no one too far away for me
yeah if you want to wait 11 years and
build leverage to be the guy then you're
young enough to do that and if that's
your passion you could do it but I hate
when people try to jump on things too
because they always lose yep you
understand yeah I'm not interested in
things that are good in theory I'm
interested in things that people are
actually doing yeah it will happen I'm
gonna [ __ ] crush VR but it's not here
that's my answer I think it's a bad idea
in the short term yeah I could be wrong
I passed on over twice in the angel
round cool cool
don't get quick Friday night you sure
Ken's last one sorry everyone I know it
sucks being the person right there right
isn't that the [ __ ] worst but it's
gonna make you more hungry like a
[ __ ] beast hey Gary how are you much
I'm Austin from blocked and collective
ROG could take could check kotecha yep
from Dubai yes yeah since he's the best
he's if he's a friggin
Tom I said what's up um just I know
you're bullish on blockchain I got so
much on traditional education just
wanted to know what you take on
accredited education education in the
blockchain space and really we we where
there's actually still a skills shortage
um I'm not sure
to be frank meaning you're talking about
accrediting over blockchain peer-to-peer
that's great no I'm talking actual
accredited education on blockchain
applied blockchain you know I think I
think there's a lot of opportunity like
look it's gonna happen yeah right so
getting ahead of stuff like that excites
me the problem is what often times just
like developers yeah we we have this big
push in 2006 78 where everybody teaches
their kids coding but then there's so
many coders at scale that the value of
the education is not as high as it used
to be yeah so I think that's where I sit
on this what's going to be the supply
and demand of that reality but what I
will tell you is the blockchain
technology is a foregone conclusion
under the amp the applications on top of
it a lot of things make sense yeah you
know and I'm excited to see how it
happens I think there'll be a lot of
people that lose a ton of money with all
the scams with icos and things of that
nature but I do think I do think
something there but I think you have to
be thoughtful of the things we learned
over the last decade on other technology
advances yeah I think the last two years
have been interesting watch yeah look
everyone's looking for a fast buck yeah
well we we developed accredited
education like through a square through
the regulatory body I understand
delivering in Dubai now and so I think
it's cool awesome thanks so much Bridget
thank you thank you busy